I actually told this story and I realized I never told this on the, on the,
on the, on the podcast, on this podcast.
But it's funny because I, this was insane.
One time when I was, um, I had to go to the bathroom so bad.
Number two, now, oopsy, Daisy. I was in public, but I don't care, dude.
You know what I do?
Do you know what I do when I got to go to the bathroom in public, number two,
do you know what I do? I go bathroom and public number two,
because that's how it is, dude.
That's how it is. If toilets are around, I'm using them. If I got to go,
I don't people with Oh, germs and like that. That's how you get sick.
And I don't use, I don't use dude. I only use the, the thing.
You know what I mean? The, the cover. I only use that when it's necessary.
Like, if there's some blood on the toilet seat or something, I wipe it off.
I get a lot of toilet paper. I wipe it off.
I wipe it off. So it doesn't touch my hand as well.
And then I put the thing on only if there was like blood or shutter,
but if there's nothing on there and I look at it and you know what I do,
I give it a once over. That's all I do.
I give it a once-over and if it's got nothing on there,
I don't use it because it's just touching my thighs. Dude. If touches your ties,
I don't give a, bro. I'm living.
Oh my God. Chris, you sat on the, you sat on the, on the toilet bowl.
What about getting and all over your balls? Is it on my.
Or is it on my thighs?
[inaudible].
So I do it and I don't give a dude,
because that's the kind of life you've got to live on gangster.
And if you're out there and if you're going to the bathroom, number two,
and you're not using those safety things, let me know.
And I won't read it, but tweeted at me and I won't read it. Um,
so I don't do as a one time. I'll also, if, if the woman's room is open,
I'm a check. If the man's room,
if the men's room is, uh, is, is,
um, used occupied, and the woman's is not.
I'm a check.
Apparently I've got to cause I'm in Loudon,
Amman loading in the women's room.
Dude. Hey sir.
What are you doing?
It looks like you got a penis and you're going in the women's room. Well,
apparently right?
No, I'm a female.
Oh my God. Are you strangling an alligator? Am I, or am I.
Taking a,
bro?
So I went into the thing, the ladies room and it wasn't a single stall.
And guess what, dude.
You up the way you made this building because this is still.
Coming out. All right.
So I go in the woman's room and I tiptoe because now I'm a woman, baby.
And I go in the stall, you know how women always tiptoe.
So I w I go in the stall and I closed the door and then,
uh, and then, uh, and then I closed the door and then, um, I'm going,
right? I'm going, and it's all good, but I'm going, it wasn't an awkward area,
but even still we'd have home with a keyboard. So, um,
so I'm in there and I'm going and a lady comes in and instantly,
I don't know why maybe it's because I'm a. My knees get real close to,
to each other because I'm scared. And I don't want anybody to see my balls.
And I'm trying to be real, real tiny. So nobody could see me,
even though I'm still six, two, and I'm a tall drink of water. Right.
And my shoulders of course are, they go on for like,
do you want to know what the weather is like on Thursday?
Because my shoulders go into next.
Weak.
You know what I mean?
You want to know what the weather's like on next Thursday while.
Let's take a ride on my shoulders,
shoulders go on for a week.
So let me know where you are and I'll tell you the forecast.
Ah, ah, all right.
So are those your shoulders?
Yes. And it's raining on Friday.
Anyway, dude, I went in there and my knees were touching together.
Cause I scared.
Cause the lady came in and she was tiptoeing because she's a lady and ladies
always tiptoe ladies have never not tiptoed. And
I'm trying to be quiet.
I'm trying not to let her come out or anything like that. You know what I mean?
I'm trying not to strangle any alligators and she's like, she says,
did a guy come in here? Did anyone see it? No. She said,
did anyone see a guy come in here?
And there's the sliver of the V the way they make these
stalls dude, maybe.
So there's no way to peek in.
You know, there's always like a gap that's like two inches wide.
And you could just literally make eye contact with people while you're dropping
off. You know what I mean?
So, so.
She looks at me
after she said, Oh, she says, does anyone see a guy come in here?
And I go like this, I go like this.
I'm like, should I make my voice? Like a woman? Like, should I literally go? No,
but I'm like, no, I'm not going to pass for that.
Right.
If it were nowadays, I would have just been like, no, and I know you've got,
you hear my voice, but I identify as a woman. I would have done that now,
but this was a while ago. So I just, I was like, should I go? No.
And I was like, nah, for sake. You know, at one time when I was a kid, once I,
when I was a kid, I didn't want to talk to him. Uh, it was,
I was in high school.
I was in eighth grade and this kid was asking me if I wanted to hang out and I
didn't want to hang out and have my number.
Cause nobody had cell phones back then. And they called me and he was like, hi,
uh, uh, I picked up the phone and I was like, hello? And he was like, Chris.
And I was like, he's going to ask to hang out. And I said, Oh no,
this is Chris's mom, Allie. And he was like, Oh,
is Chris there? And I said, and I literally, I literally said,
I L this is the truth. I swear to God. I literally said, Oh no,
he's at the.
Opera. Ha.
He said, okay, well tell him to call me back. It's David or whoever. Well,
I don't remember who it was. And I said, okay, click. And I remember thinking,
well,
he'll believe that because why the would I pretend I was my mom and say Chris
was at the opera because what the? There's not operas that go on at, well,
maybe they do. I don't know, but not, not in lock-in Jada at 5:00 PM.
So anyway, I, uh, I didn't do that voice. I just, I said,
she said, did anyone see a guy come in here? And I said, no. And I, as I say,
no, I look at out the crack of the doors and I'm making eye
contact with her with one.
Eye. And I'm.
Looking at her and I say no. And she just said,
did anyone see a guy come in here? And I say, no,
and I am a guy.
Oh, what?
And then.
Oh, no, I didn't say no. I said what? I said, what? Which is even better.
That's so much of a. I was, she said, I want to see a guy come in here.
And I said, what? And I'm looking at her.
And she says, uh.
And I S and then she says again, and I swear to God,
this was the only time that's ever happened in my entire life. She said, I said,
did anyone see an iPhone in here? I heard the wrong thing. Cause I was scared.
I'm a. That was the first. That was the only time that ever happened to me.
It was like, that happens in movies. And you're like, Oh, get, go, yourself.
Dude, go yourself. You know? But it really happened. And I said,
Oh no, no iPhone. And she just walked out tiptoeing like a lady.
And I finished up strangling my alligator. And then I walked a man.
It was up that day, dude. Did you know that? So
It was good man.
One time my friend said he was in a foreign country with his brother and he was
drinking with his brother and he and his brother confined
abroad for a little bit.
And he was outside and there was a huge pile of throw up
on the ground. And he was leaning up against the wall. And my buddy said, Hey,
did you just throw up? And he said, I don't know.
Uh, caught red handed. I don't know,
hit.
I don't know, dude, not straight up lie. No,
I don't know is the best to say, I don't know
when you know, and you're trying to get out of not being a,
you know, in trouble or whatever you think is the best. I don't know.
I don't know.
That's my favorite kind of. And that's final.
So you can argue with me all day long, but that's my favorite kind of.
And that's fun because we know what we like. We know what daddy likes.
We know what daddy likes that he likes when guys are some
and they try to not be some. That's the best thing.
If a guy's wearing sunglasses at night and bumps into a thing,
that's my favorite thing. And that's the end of story, dude. I says,
okay,